thank you
heroic entrances are great these Dynamic
entries set the tone so well that I made
some videos to share some of my favorite
ones from anime but why not up the ante
a little bit now why start with A Single
Character entrance when we can shake
things up a bit this time and focus on
group entrances here are some of my
favorite group entrances in Shonen anime
by the end of it all I do hope that this
video will either refresh your memory on
these awesome moments we'll give you a
dose of adrenaline like they did with me
when I first saw them I think moving
forward these moment videos should have
a default spoiler warning with that
being said let's get on with the list
with bleach thousand year Wars first
core finale and the stunningly great
reception it got I was reminded of this
moment in the fulbring arc
foreign
[Music]
Arc isn't an arc that people look back
on fondly sure it's got its fans but
it's also arguable that this is the arc
where bleacher's popularity tanked
relative to how big it was in the 2000s
some people cite the change in Formula
other site what it felt like after Story
Philip Eisen had been defeated some
people just plain Mr Shinigami the
latter though gets rectified in one of
the best moments the ark gave us it's a
gripping moment after Ichigo gets
betrayed and was at his lowest just when
he thought even his dad and urahara had
betrayed him he gets stabbed by a sword
does that seem familiar a call back to
the first episode eh but this time
rookia didn't come alone along with her
were all the other Shinigami who had
forged a deep bond with Ichigo his
biggest Rivals and biggest friends and
toshiro who's there for reasons that
thousand year blood will shed light on
the whole thing felt like a great
reunion between friends and it's a great
way to open up the finale of The Ark
because sometimes it does take a little
push from your comrades to rise from the
depths of despair
assistant
oh
speaking of friends looking out for one
another the black balls entrance is one
of my favorite Black Clover moments
now while they are surrounding this
moment doesn't quite have as much of an
emotional and story-wise stake for the
main character is the Ichigo one this
one makes up for it with how badass and
proactive it was the black ball saving
finra was a moment that happened in a
Flash and was over with quickly but told
a thousand words in the span of just a
few seconds there aren't a lot of main
character groups and teams that are as
fire forged as the black Bulls their
chemistry is impeccable and the way they
fiercely defend each other was
exemplified in this moment finra out may
be quite the eccentric personality
amongst the black balls one who I
wouldn't be surprised people find
annoying at times however we're talking
about a team where no one's Left Behind
that's why Asta and the Gang quickly
step in in such a manner and you can
really see with the look in their eyes
at their serious languorous has gone too
far and they will make him pay for it
sometimes it doesn't take a grand
entrance to make a statement instead of
giving some time to let that moment sink
in quick and to the point does the job
just as well
foreign
next is a rather underrated Shonen
My Parade of a hundred demons does sound
really cool which is part of the charm
of the show when you find out that said
night parade is a fun-loving group of
Yokai who live to party and have fun oh
an engaging Clan Wars too since they're
modeled after the Yakuza the latter
description is certainly what the rat
demon saw when the group came knocking
at their doorstep to rescue Ghana and
Yura it's a chilling sight to enemies
one that emphasizes the side of the nura
clan that most anime viewers don't get
to see for much of season one's run but
here they're all business and Rico alone
easily takes care of these rats like the
small fries that they are it's quite
intimidating yet calming when it's all
said and done a perfect representation
of rikuo is a character noorar is an
underrated Shonen it's got two seasons
and while it ends in a cliffhanger the
journey is worth it I do really wish
more people watched it
[Music]
Dynamic entries like these are best done
by Heroes and there's no better group of
people to do it than these guys led by
all mites
[Music]
all might lead in the charge is always a
sight to see but to have it in the form
of rescuing one of his important
students one he had so much history with
makes this moment a lot better than it
was on paper now like the previous
featured moment all it took was a few
seconds for the heroes to go to work
this time quickly disabling everyone in
sight while showcasing some of their
amazing powers in a Flash the whole
apartment's been contained and it's just
a testament to the hero's teamwork and
how they took this operation with every
inch of preparation the preemptive
attack done so effectively we even get
to see all might have his little moment
with bark will go there
and if you're enjoying the video why not
hit the like button up there a like will
help YouTube recommend more videos like
this to you and it will help my channel
do well as well it only takes a few
seconds it'll make me very happy and
will tell me that you like these kind of
videos so thank you so much for your
help we come back with some Marquee
goodness how about Sinbad's entrance
with the seven seats Alliance
best ending to an episode ever you know
it's somewhat of a hardcore with Margie
because just before this moment we have
the co Empire Nobles making their big
entrance to help Aladdin and friends
they didn't disappoint either making
quick work of most enemies and easily
fodderizing them it's just that they had
to run into pretty much an invincible
opponent which prompted this entrance
for so long we've heard of the Seven
Seas Alliance we know they're there and
that they're strong but this is the
first time we get to see them the hype
was off the chance to see the leaders
all go into their gin equips with the
Finishing Touch being Sinbad dealing
what seemed to be a decisive blow to
complete the entrance and the best part
of it the speech you did to cap off the
sequence the conviction in his voice
blending well with the soothing and
mystical feel of the Ed themes first few
beats one of the best Cliffhangers in
Shonen anime and it's in Margie
in Canada
next up let's give a shout out to attack
on Titan
[Applause]
ium
Attack on Titans coming back to wrap
things up so let's welcome it with a
feature on this list the series is Rife
with blood pumping entrances and flashy
twists and fights but if we're talking
about group entrances I'd like to give
some love to the survey called saving
Krista Krista was on the verge of being
eaten before Mikasa jumps in to save the
day and along with her the rest of the
survey corpse I've always loved Attack
on Titan in terms of the execution of
pivotal moments and the way the
atmosphere was set up here was nothing
short of Awesome The Silence mikasa's
reassuring words then the Titans all
falling in short order as the rest of
the crew make easy work of them sure did
a great job in playing with their
emotions and of course there's always
the exciting part of seeing these Titans
get demolished by the strongest
Defenders Humanity has sure it's just
them fighting photos but that doesn't
take away from the moment especially
when you're seated immersed in the show
and watching with your full attention
you mean
Naruto's entrance with the Toads Finds
Its way to the list
[Applause]
Naruto has always been a story about
overcoming adversity right that even if
everyone looks down on you there's hope
for you to come around and become the
hero with just a little bit of hard work
some talent and an unrelenting
determination one of the strongest
moments that build to that theme is
Naruto becoming konoha's Savior and he
started everything with what has now
become an iconic entrance that pose has
truly become legendary hasn't it but him
coming back to save everyone was a
moment that sent chills down every Fan's
spine Naruto may have been a polarizing
show in its Heyday but when it comes to
drive a point home and make a moment
look epic and important it hits a home
run on those and this one is no
exception you just knew that business is
about to pick up when you saw Naruto
with the Toads Standing Tall and ready
to fight Pain the fight itself is
likewise epic but we'll save that one
for another time
while Naruto's entrance got us hyped for
a confrontation here's Shanks doing the
opposite
[Applause]
Shanks just did The Impossible while it
seems that the Marine football is an
inevitability the guy puts an end to it
by just appearing with his crew which
has become a thing of Legend I really
love this moment because you can feel
this impact so much with how odar
plotted everything out the timing of the
group entrance is perfect and it pairs
so well with the heroic save that came
beforehand and then the chef's kiss just
look at how everyone scared shitless
while Shanks looks like he's totally in
control of the situation I mean it's
really hard to imagine someone like
freaking akinu being stopped so easily
by this mere appearance and there's
Blackbeard stopping too Blackbeard this
is only one part of a great art but it's
one that I'll always remember sure it's
not the top of the list of memorable
moments with the art being such an
emotional roller coaster but as far as
group entrances are this is one of the
best ones with or without my bias for
One Piece
foreign
[Music]
and that concludes my list for best
group entrances and shown in anime I
hope you enjoyed watching this one and I
hope that the list brought back some
nostalgic memories for you or that
you're now going to go and check out
these shows if you're up for more lists
like this make sure to check out the
channel I upload videos multiple times a
week so you'll have a lot of lists to go
through thanks a lot for watching and
here's to an even better 2023 I'll see
you next time